مئات الاشخاص خرجوا في مسيره في شوارع
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط تمديدا بتدهور
الاوضاع الاجتماعيه واحتجاجا على غلاء
المعيشه المسيره دعت اليها مجموعه من
الاحزاب السياسيه والمنظمات الحقوقيه
والنقابيه على راسها تنسيقيه الجبهه
الاجتماعيه المغربيه
[موسيقى]
باش نقولوا ان الدوله مطالبه باعاده النظر
سياسات العموميه ديالها
التي شارك فيها النشاط
بيرجع لي حد للاستبداد والفساد الذين
يعاني منهما الشعب المغربي منذ سنوات يريد
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه نريد حريات نريد قضاء
مستقله اذن احنا اليوم مستنكر هذا
الاختيارات الايام متبعه من اجل ان يتمتع
الشعب المغربي بكل افراده بالحق يعني في
الحريه
التي ترى راسها عزيز اخنوش انها تدعم
الفئات الاولى بالرعايه باجراءات مثل رفع
الحد الادنى للاجور وتطبيقي نظامي على
كافه المغاربه وكانت المندوبيه الساميه
لتخطيط قالت في وقت سابقا
دفعت بنحو ثلاثه ملايين مغربي